before we get started this is a Jack
Murphy wrote a book Democrat to
deplorable former former Democrat now on
the Trump train I guess this is a fair
way to say it absolutely and you wrote a
book about it and if you would like to
ask questions hop in the super chat we
will take questions after the segments
and then we have a bunch of stuff we're
gonna talk about and I think we
shouldn't go for it cuz Jack's got a
yeah real interesting really interesting
guy I don't you for a little while and I
think it's been a couple of years now
we've had a bunch of real interesting
conversations and the first and most
important is your book Democrats
deplorable why not let me just show it
why nine million Obama voters ditch the
Democrats and embrace Donald Trump and
you wrote that so I did I wrote I wrote
it in over 2016-2017 published in 2018
so it's been out for a couple of years
now and the main shift behind it is that
this is a cultural phenomenon it's not a
it's not politics it's not necessarily
about tax cuts or anything like that
it's about culture it's about reason and
science it's actually it's actually
about order versus chaos and people
people called Trump the chaos candidate
but that was actually a misnomer he was
the one that we actually were supporting
to take us back to some semblance of
order I think a lot of people were
starting to feel crazy start to feel
crazy when all these issues the cultural
issues that are hot buttons today like
radical feminism intersectionality all
this hyper focus on race when you know
I'm a Gen X guy I was raised to not
think about race yeah and that's how I
was you know came up my whole life but
then starting in 2012 you know coming
into 2015 all of a sudden everybody's
talking about race race race all the
time and they're all pointing their
finger at me this is just white guy why
why are you putting forgive me what did
I do
yep I was an ally I was here as I was
here to help so I don't know yeah what's
it what's what's in the book and then
well we got a budget I don't talk about
but sure yeah yeah so the main thrust of
the book is there's three sections to it
the first part is my my my story about
how I came up in this sort of non-racial
you know don't see color don't see
gender you know I was bused across town
as part of like a desegregation scheme
so I really yes wait wasn't that called
busing wasn't busing yeah yeah I was
actually part of the busing in Indiana
I guess in the 80s yeah I was bust from
the suburbs all the way into the city
and so like for like mix that's a mean
it's the racist yeah so I was a part of
like a very radical social experiment
basically from my whole life so whether
I wanted it or not I have kind of been
thrust into this story since the very
beginning and what I was gonna yeah and
so the first part of the the book is
just sort of laying the groundwork for
somebody like myself and I ended up
working in charter schools I ran charter
schools executive director of charter
schools in Washington DC with 99.99%
african-american population everybody
under the poverty line I was dedicated a
hundred percent dedicated to helping
minority students in the city urban
education like what could be a more
progressive cause cause than that and I
believed in it I believe in education
but eventually my race and gender became
a problem being a white man stood in my
way of getting things done I remember
the very first day I got there I started
as a CFO they gave me like a whole
pamphlet on like how black people do
business differently than white people
and how I needed to change my way of
doing business to accommodate this black
culture that I was now part of how was
it gonna make things better well you
know there's just a different way of
doing things yeah apparently and it
started with those kind of conversations
which is you know you can I can see a
place for trying to figure out how to
interact with people that may not be of
your particular culture but now later on
in my career it got to the point where
now everything is white supremacy so
like being on time is white supremacy or
your reliance on data is white supremacy
rationality and science and math this is
all these are all now stated white
supremacy ideas I got to do it I got it
I got to jump in I got to tell you story
Thome I don't know if I told you this
one when I would never tell you a story
about when I went to North Dakota for
the Dakota access pipeline stuff and the
fight I got into so I got it was it was
a big story I knew people who were there
so I decided to go check it out a lot of
those people like hate my guts it's
really weird like some good friends had
for years just like snapped and now
they've just think I don't know it's
weird they've gone off the rails
but a friend and I went out there we
meet some people
they invited
we go to launch we get pizza I've got to
be in Los Angeles in like a week and I'm
in North Dakota in the winter in a Honda
Civic mm-hmm it was that great journey
to say the least like I almost died
several times so I'm talking at this
table everyone's getting along we all
kind of agree you know I mean I'm there
in like a journalistic capacity I'm not
here to say you're right or wrong I'm
just be like tell me your story right
and so I told a guy I told everybody I
wish I could stay but I have to leave by
tomorrow so I can make it to LA in two
days and the guy said no dude dude you
guys that's colonial thinking man and I
said what do you mean that's colonial
thinking he goes like like schedules you
know like time like you gotta be there
this time the Native Americans don't
have that you know they do things when
they need to get done that's colonial
and I was like what does colonial
thinking mean I don't understand what
that word is supposed to represent like
and he said it was the white Europeans
who brought schedules to the rest of the
world and I was like excuse me dude I'm
part Korean okay like we have sense of
time and scheduling we know how to farm
and we knew when we had to do it yeah
okay we had time - it wasn't given to us
and he goes come on spy on us man we all
know that was the white people who
brought that stuff to East Asia and I
was just like excuse me mother I was
like I'm not gonna say I got mad I
really got mad I was I was legit mad I'm
like I am sick and tired of white
supremacists like you telling me that my
culture was made by you when we did it a
thousand years before you did because he
was the white guy telling me like my
culture was built by him and that's why
like when I hear the stories like what
you're telling me yeah I'm like dude
that resonates I grew up in Chicago we
were in it was a mixed area we all got
along none of this was ever an issue
until I went to New York docu Pie Wall
Street and all of a sudden I met these
people who had segregated themselves but
you did not occupy wall street they
actually had voting block based on race
how could you not and I remember this is
really funny I hated I was like these
people are nuts I remember one day there
was a black dude chilling on this
planter ledge and he was arguing saying
y'all dudes are crazy and I was like I
was like what's up what do you think and
he's like do you have any idea what the
press is gonna say if they walk over
here and see segregation in this park
and I started laughing
like fist-pump dude I get it yeah I mean
I remember I ended up working for the
regulator for charter schools first yeah
finance I was like the CNN senior
finance director and I walk into a room
and on the whiteboard is their vision
for the future of this organization's
government organization and on the
whiteboard is has too many white people
so they weren't even hiding it this is a
government-run agency in the district
Columbia and on the white board in their
brainstorming session about what the
future of this agency should look like
segregationists there no just don't hire
any more white people get rid of the
white people and hire nothing but POC
and people in the rainbow flag and I
absolutely have no problem with this
i-i've hired like over a hundred you
know african-americans and gay people
and whatever train them all I don't care
I'm looking for a performance right but
they very specifically are all focused
on what do you look like what's between
your legs and not what's between your
head and this is basically the general
thrust of the book Democrats are
deplorable right available on Amazon you
can it's a story about me and then it's
a story I interviewed 1,500 people
across the country well we did a
national survey yeah we interviewed
people from all over I got my car and
just drove all over the East Coast went
through Pennsylvania backwater
Pennsylvania that country rather and
it's the stories of those people and
then I tie it all together the biggest
issues the biggest issues being
globalism being the China is ascension
into the WTO what that's it's a
manufacturing base radical feminism
intersectionality what's going on
college campuses about how when you walk
in the door on the very first day and
orientation or like introduce yourself
by your gender yeah and here's how this
is rape culture and here's how if you
are an accuser you'll never have to
participate in any sort of hearing
against you know if a rape or whatever
and men don't have any rights etc etc so
I tie it all together and then basically
the big the big finish is talking about
how the media the academic academics the
the marketing the technology the deep
state everybody has swallowed this same
pill that's called the blue church and I
didn't coin that phrase that's Jordan
halls phrase blue church but basically
the blue chairs come to dominate
everything we can see it and we can see
it today and so now people that vote for
Trump this is a insurgency it's a
the red insurgents we are an emergent
network that has taken over the
Republican Party and it's much in the
same way that Bernie's people are trying
to take over the Democratic Party and
you can see parallels in both the
Republican establishment and the
Democratic establishment in trying to
repel these invaders right yeah you know
we basically the Trump phenomenon took
over the the GOP yep you know he was we
were talking about this earlier he's
basically a New York Democrat right and
he took over the Republican Party
because it was the easiest way for him
to get his agenda done Democrats would
never elect a billionaire I don't think
so at least no I don't know I don't know
I don't even know what a Democrat is
anymore so a great foreign to me yes so
but I bring up this point all the time
if I said to you Democrat what do you
think do you think a socialist like aoc
or Bernie Sanders do you think a Joe
Biden warmonger corporate Goldman Sachs
hemant I mean today I think a single 35
year old white woman who can't get a
date and is upset and miserable and
drinks too much wine and has cats that's
what I think of and then cries about
racism all day everywhere misogyny all
day everywhere well there's no good men
left that's what I think of I think
there were some points in there there
were a bit hyperbolic what your no your
but you're not actually wrong a Pew
Research did a survey 68 percent of
millennial women are Democrats yeah and
I think it's something like 43 percent
are men meaning there is a large there's
a large portion of millennial Democratic
females who are single yeah yeah and and
millennial men are turning towards the
Republican Party and so this is the last
thing I haven't talked about in the book
is just this attack on masculinity
basically and so the Democrats are
basically the anti masculinity feminine
feminized the culture de-risk the
culture party and the Republicans are
now the party of masculine power and
masculine energy so here's here's what
freaks me out I was I was a I was a big
fan of Bernie in 2015-16 but his tune
has changed have you seen the interviews
from him back in 2015 have you seen the
news stories no you you you know a lot
of his talking points overlapped with
Trump well yeah some of the economic
populist not definitely absolutely yeah
and they were and there were so many
articles being like Trump and Bernie are
so similar and that was actually a
threat to Bernie because Trump is this
boorish bombastic you know arrogant dude
right a lot of people love
but Bernie was the career politician who
represented some similar things today
Bernie's talking points are flipping
like within the month
right well this brings up a good
question a decent chunk of the nine
million Democrats that voted for nine
point four nine four voted for Trump a
decent chunk of them were like burned
Bernie Sanders supporters right so right
i chronicled one lady who was a Bernie
supporter delegate in a Bernie delegate
in Nevada in the caucuses and then saw
how Hillary stole Nevada from from
Bernie and then went to Philadelphia and
then saw how they treated all the Bernie
delegates yeah the whole thing and so
she was like if this yeah I'm not gonna
be a part of this and she went full
Trump and now her whole life has changed
she's like been introduced to new
cultural ideas and new norms and new
ways of nicer people like you know and
that's the first thing she said in my
interview actually yeah I couldn't
believe how nice everybody was right you
know the I think it's an Andrew bright
part quote about walking towards the
fire mmm no but that's a good place to
go if you can't be in journalism I'm not
sure if it's from him and I'm probably
in the freight that it wrong but the ID
it's something like people are default
liberal and they're standing behind this
wall of fire and they're scared of it
but once you walk through it you realize
on the other side is freedom and like
yeah I'm probably ruining it yes but
that's absolutely right so to follow up
on that last point though it was like
are those Bernie people who felt you
know disenfranchised from Democratic
Party in 2016 will they if bernie is the
nominee will they return to vote
democrat in 2020 I think some of them
definitely will but I think some of them
are definitely gonna stick with Trump
yep
and if Bernie I know that for a fact is
for real the the nominee then I think
that they'll lose a lot of the moderate
people you know who just soar like
socialists I don't want anything do with
that I was in Anaheim and there was a
trump rally these three guys two young
guys and an older guy got jumped
they got chased by a bunch of like
Antipa types stealing their hats
spinning on him punching them as they
ran away I interviewed the guy
afterwards and he said they were Bernie
supporters all three of them the two
young guys the older guy and he said
they were supporting Bernie because he
was a politician they felt he had the
experience and government to get the job
done
he was about trade he wanted to you know
Trump Bernie was talking about TPP being
bad about NAFTA being bad he was talking
about workers he said open borders a
coke brothers proposal it's bad for the
workers in America they supported that
right that was back then
then when the nomination was stolen they
said Trump was the only option for them
because he was the only one talking
about how these these policies hurt them
yeah and they got attacked by these
people because now they support Trump
right but let me let me tell you
something you know what really scares me
Bernie was talking with these things in
2015
today he's fully on board the
intersectional whoa aaaahhhh see I don't
think you guys listening or watching and
you PI don't know if you know this have
you ever been to Berkeley California
yeah
no you go to Berkeley walk down like the
main you know Avenue just outside of the
university and you'll see on inside
every window is like the feminist
revolution fist on a poster every
business down several blocks is a sign
saying we support these causes and we
hate Trump and I went to a bar and they
had a a post that said Trump is you know
and they called him a disparaging term I
was sitting there eating food mind my
own business
bartender seemed very nice lovely lady
and I asked her I was like what is
what's the sign mean cuz a different
language and she was like oh it's you
know we're insulting Trump and I was
like do you not like him do you hate him
and she was like I don't really care and
I was like then why do you have the sign
in your window because if we don't
they'll smash it mmm in Oakland there
was a Burger King and I saw this in like
2014 with a sign in the window saying
please do not smash our windows we are a
family-owned franchise not a corporate
store that's the future that awaits you
when these people gain more ground and
become more powerful and people don't
people don't know this they see they see
you know these terrible movies and the
insults and cancel culture and think oh
well it's no big deal but they don't
realize that if these people truly got
what they wanted you would not be able
to go outside unless you put flags on
your house saying yes please we support
whatever you say please don't hurt us
it's very very much so like what they
kind of did in World War Two in a
certain country hmm I don't want to say
because I don't want to play that game I
don't want to draw that parallel but you
look at the photos from Hamburg Germany
during the g20 a couple years ago and
there's a there is a row of storefronts
all smashed save one you know
the one store right in the middle wasn't
smashed up tell me they had a revolution
fist in the window and so the the anti
faloona tix spared their store because
they bent the knee well you know Tim I
have very personal experience with
antiva right so as I'm working for these
charter schools as I'm working for the
regulator I like you I write and cover
various you know issues and I went to an
end Tifa protest and Tifa versus the
alt-right Richard Spencer and all those
guys Jason Kessler they were all down
the White House so I went down there
just to check it out I stand in the
middle to take pictures right so I'm in
a picture with Jason Kessler just
happens oh yeah okay then I get into a
picture I'm in a picture with Jack the
sobic and chelsea manning okay all right
yep so they see me in this picture with
Chelsea Manning and Jack with sobic and
they're like who is this guy he must be
alright so they try to identify me they
find me they find this picture with me
and Jason Kessler then they take that
picture and send it to my work and they
say hey this guy is a Nazi he is look at
him he's at Kessler this is a Charles
'full guy he's a Nazi you should fire
him and within 12 hours I was suspended
and in two months later I was totally
fired yep yeah and Tifa has come for me
they've stolen away my career my
reputation
they doxxed me they got me fired from
banned from coaching Little League okay
like yeah it went all the way through to
them taking the trying to destroy my
entire life they even somehow we're
getting in touch with like my landlord
trying to get me evicted okay all the
way down this is a antifa
trying to go after me just because I
happened to be in a picture yep with
somebody who they thought was a bad guy
while the whole time I'm actually one of
the few people in Washington DC that's
ever turned around a school in deep in
the urban inner city and helped
african-american students get better
education and it's all quantified and
you can research it and see it it's all
right there it's real data
they don't care though they don't care
it's about the tribe it's about the
ideology there's no rules like mean
there's like loose rules but the one
important rule is don't cross us right
so it's it's a chaotic and destructive
forest with no mission and so when I
look at what the you know it look man I
i I don't think that I've never been a
person who feels like the solution is
voting against voting for the other
party who's not as
I just don't like it so I don't want to
do it right no but I look at the
Democrats today they're accusing each
other of cheating you know Iowa caucus
was a disaster
mayor cheat was trending on Twitter I
saw them they liked that a lot
they booed him you can actually turn the
mic like that okay right on yeah they
booed him in New Hampshire they're in
chaos you know and actually I think we
can go we can talk about what happen
with Pelosi because that's resulted in a
lot more Democrats saying they were done
this was the last straw for them I can't
I can't believe it
the big one of the biggest complaints
that many people have had which I've
certainly brought up is Trump does not
represent the office well in terms of
like when I think of the president as
this honorable and they haven't always
been I understand that it's not the
biggest issue to me but have they ever
actually like I mean if you think back
think back JFK like oral sex secretaries
you know I get it I get it right and LBJ
and think about farther and farther back
I think it's just like a myth right no
no I don't agree so that's that's why
it's not the biggest issue for me yeah
but the reason I bring it up is then you
get you know Joe Biden called the new
fad called the dude a liar tells people
go vote for somebody else he's certainly
not doing that anything special
Elizabeth Warren just called my pensive
dog and Pelosi stands up and shreds his
speech and they want to tell me oh but
Trump is the bad guy and I'm like you're
all the same dude look I get it man he's
got a bad attitude but the media gives
him a way worse rap than he really has
yeah I just I'm ambivalent I'm like I
wouldn't pick him myself so you know for
me my attitude is they I mean I'm one of
the people who desperately tried to say
give me a reason to stick with with the
Democratic Party yeah absolutely not I
think after Iowa I just said I am done
they changed the rules so that Bloomberg
has an easier chance again on the debate
stage I couldn't believe that is such a
crock that that to me was like there's
nothing even subtle about that I know so
overt money he has money and power and
we want to use his money in power he's
on the stage he gave them over a million
dollars he gave Democratic aligned group
like 700 something and the DNC like 300
and there it was Tulsi yang the people I
was interested in were and then and
they've already had the media coming
after them you know what I mean Tulsi
has been smeared relentlessly and I was
like if I can't Eve
support somebody so they come in the
debate stage knowing they're not gonna
win I'm not playing I'm done I'm walking
away I'm you know that doesn't mean I'm
gonna go the other side of the aisle and
go talk to that you know I have nope but
here's the thing
waters warm over here plus it's really
nice once you walk through the fire Tim
well I know I've been to the fire you
know I mean I think I think a great
example of being through the fire is the
fact that I can sit here and say like I
don't like I might want to vote for him
and you're not hitting me over the head
with a club like if or what would happen
if you went in front of an tyfa and said
you were considering voting for Trump
they'd scream in your face they'd hit
you it's the worst possible things and
it an even outside of like the crazy
ante fo types you'll get like zealot
people who are gonna be like are you a
fascist ooh no new face it's my own
family Tim you know it's like just by
this is when I started to discover
things were really messed up in 2014 or
so you know I would start I was weren't
very active on Facebook just and not
even like as a social media person just
like my family and friends and I would
post articles that just questioned the
general narratives that were ongoing and
and just ask questions and live or even
2016 election like I had alienated half
my family I've completely alienated for
my entire Democratic irish-catholic
family they want some of them won't even
talk to me anymore because I just
started challenging their notions and
then when you know whole-hog and what
went for it because I saw where we
needed to go but like it's not just the
crazy antiva types it's it's filtering
down through every human interaction
that we have who your friends are who
your may is gonna be dating your love
life what it's like for your kids to be
at school if parents know that you're a
trump supporter and they're there with
your kids in the same classroom my
little daughter my six-year-old daughter
at the time she took some of my swag my
Democrats at adorable swag did I didn't
know this took it into school for show
and tell
okay and I we live in Washington DC okay
which is like the bluest yeah place in
the hosts in the whole country and she
brings it in and they're like my daddy
wrote a book Democrats at deplorable and
I was so proud and and and one of the
kids was like what's a deplorable and
they had to like shut the whole thing
down and I felt really bad for her
because she didn't know
she was just being proud but it's
everywhere it's in it's in all of your
social relationships decoding markets
it's everywhere we went to a game shop
just I play Magic the Gathering its card
game I see I guess yeah yeah we got a
whole bunch I'm so excited we're just
we're getting it set up so we can
actually play like some nice fun games
maybe film them but this the shop had a
sign in the window that said this is a
safe space it did not feel like a safe
space because as much as I understand
what they're trying to accomplish with
that phrase it's associated with this
very violent ideology and I've seen the
physical ramifications of those who dare
oppose it oh my god do I walk my dog
around my neighborhood and every other
house on my street as a black lives
matter sign or another sign that says
like everyone is welcome here and it
lists all the people who are welcome but
like straight whites is I'm saying s' is
as mocking and white straight doesn't
say straight whites is dudes there's
nowhere on the list right you're not
welcome not welcome but it's like the
crazy thing about it is you can
literally just say you're anything it
doesn't even make it doesn't make sense
but they wouldn't they wouldn't know
they wouldn't believe me because yeah
they cuz they can read my mind
Tim and now of course that's what it is
it's all about them being able to read
my mind
and that and it's like impeachment like
they didn't ask a single question about
Trump's motivation with the cut phone
call for Ukraine they just asserted it
right and now the media reports it like
it's true well we'll save the media
stuff well I wanna stick to this yeah ah
there was a segment that cut I did a
couple days ago Nancy Pelosi stands up
shreds Trump's speech actually I don't
know if you caught this she tried she
ripped it a little bit first yeah did
you notice that I did she had too many
pages in there serums couldn't do it
well no no no before he finished his
speech she pulls him down and she rips
him a little bit and puts him back oh so
she could just make an easy rip for a
show I think she was testing to see if
she could if she could rip it cuz maybe
it was a stronger like maybe a plastic
you know kind of kind of piece paper
fancy white house big fancy white house
paper and so she claims with because the
speech was full of Lies Trumpton
finished the speech before she prepared
to actually rip it and you can see it
but anyway she rips it up and I was
shocked
like I was I'm sitting right over here
and we're playing we're playing the
speech and we're cracking jokes I said
to my to Adam who's you know who
normally coasts the show everything
Trump sound says is so amazing his
speech was a Matt was it was like magic
there were a few things we as like
levels left-leaning Democrat voters were
like oh I don't know about that one
but my buddy Adams like I don't
understand why they're not clapping for
you know Trump said women 70% of women
got the jobs from that from the big job
bring right not a lie they're not
standing up for it and I said Adam you
got to realize that Trump is telling you
all of the best stuff
he's not gonna criticize himself right
and so at that point there was an
opening for for me and my buddy who have
always been very left-leaning kind of
dude it's like we're skateboarding you
know you know just kind of city urban
hippie kind of people and then when it
ended Pelosi stood up in a rip and are
we both were just like what did she just
do the narrative change in a second
yeah no longer were we even considering
what Trump said we'll do you think that
that was deliberate do you think that
she was smart enough to steal the news
cycle with that that's I've heard a lot
of people say no she made a serious
serious mistake yeah I think the
Democrats did in general we're watching
this with my kids right
and every time Trump says something good
and the Democrats don't stand up my son
goes I hate women and then something
else happened he goes I hate black
people and somebody else I hate like
those are all gonna get cut out of
context by the way but this is this is
him making fun of the Democrats sitting
down right whenever Trump is like black
unemployment is their lows you know
minority unemployment all-time lows
women are getting hired at all rated at
all this wonderful stuff that you would
think that they would be totally
championing they just sat there and
looked because they hate Trump that's
their policy issue it's not about if
Trump's accomplishing any things don't
like the guy
Kyrsten Sinema stood up for a lot I did
but then she floated for impeachment
yeah so anyway I bring this up because
in the wake of this a bunch of people
called into c-span and it was it was
shocking I mean when I when I did the
segment on it I read the transcripts but
if you you really gotta listen to these
people one old dude he's like I've been
a Democrat for 77 years I am done what
she did was an embarrassment to all of
us this is the president United States
and and I felt like a lot of these
people were saying what they were saying
resonated so much with me because I
always say you don't have to like Trump
but you do have to be an adult and being
adult means sometimes the guy you don't
like wins you know that means that means
I'll go vote in the next election
because it's a it's a back and forth
Bush won Obama won Clinton Reagan you
know I guess go go on and so forth
but we're at a point now where since
2016 they won't stop it's it's
ridiculous scandals it's fake news
smears it's the most insane trash yeah
so like 9 million people voted for Obama
are for Trump that had voted for Obama I
think that that number that Democrats a
deplorable number is going to increase
only increase there's not there's not
once you once you go to this side
you're also not coming back either I
don't think like nobody who decided and
stood up and probably voted for Trump
after they had been with Obama it's not
gonna all of a sudden be like oh it's
time for me to go back to you know to
Mayor Pete right and and I and I really
think that this number this nine million
number is gonna continue to grow and
you're seeing it now like a Jeffrey
Miller evil psych professor a very kind
of famous guy he put out a tweet the
other day saying just this very thing
like I'm they're finally losing me the
Democrats yeah and it blew up I mean
like thousands and thousands and
thousands of retweets and people are all
chiming and they're all saying the same
thing now all these people in the threat
are all saying the same thing that
Democrats have completely lost me and
it's me lost me but David I'm I'm so
desperate you can see it my face I'm
like I won't vote for Trump but it's
like but you know the the Democrats it's
not the same party obviously yeah that
it was the unten or 15 years ago and
it's about these new networks these new
networks that are emerging and taking
over the party and like aoc is one of
them and it's just this it's they're
finding a way to find their power and
it's through the democratic party right
and just the same way Trump did through
the through the Republicans but there's
absolutely no way I can be a part of a
caucus that has at its core people whose
main philosophy is that straight white
guys ruin the world and we need to get
rid of them like Ikea
how can I get in that but I mean you
don't even say like that yeah I can't
get behind a party that has racism at
its core right and but let me explain
because I'm not talking about why people
I'm talking about my family and there's
a lot of people got mad at me like I'm
not like really mad like you know down
with Tim but they were like Tim when you
get mad because they're targeting Asians
like how do you feel how do you think
the you know white people feel when they
talk at white people and I I agree I
understand I respect that I'm mostly
white I come from a mixed family
everybody knows it it's like a meme but
I but I mean this seriously when
they did that lawsuit with Harvard yeah
about Asians I'm like you realize when
they say Asian they're talking about
India they're talking about certain
parts of the Middle East they're talking
about Southeast Asia South Asia East
Asia you cannot compare someone from
Thailand to a wealthy Chinese immigrant
but that's what they're doing and so
what I say to people is if you really
want to understand the racism at the
core of this ideology I want you to go
find a 13 year old American Asian child
who was born here who grew up here look
them in the eyes and say you aren't
allowed to go to an Ivy League college
because you look too much like those
people that's what you're saying yeah I
what Asians are now gonna be a white
adjacent they already are yeah that's
exactly what it is you know I love that
phrase and it's gonna keep I love it
because I said terrible and disgusting
and whatever but like I in some in some
respects we should be acceleration
astana particular element because the
crazier it gets the more quickly or the
faster it does I think the more the
sooner it could be resolved right I'm
hoping I just don't think I think I
don't think it matters the snowballs are
rolling down the hill it's getting
bigger and bigger you couldn't stop it
if you want it to well intersectionality
has at its core like a shrink
right so it just keeps identifying all
these cross-sections of oppression and
this and that before you know it there's
gonna be one person standing in the
middle saying all of you people are
against me and maybe all of us on the
outside finally can be like this is this
is pretty dumb I think it's gonna happen
in November you think so you know I'm
actually kind of worried though because
what we just saw that guy plow that that
vehicle through the Republican tent
yeah it's gonna be a hot summer Tim oh
yeah it's and it's not gonna be because
of Trump it's gonna be when they rob
Bernie Sanders thanks for checking out
this segment from the Tim cast IRL
podcast we do the show every Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. sometimes an
hour or two and we do have a full live
recorded version of the show that
includes a lot of comments and smaller
segments you probably don't see if you
want to check that out you can watch
live at 8:00 p.m. Monday through Friday
or become a member of this channel and
for five bucks a month you get full
access to all of the recorded podcasts
every day after the show we make them
available in the community section of
this YouTube channel so don't forget to
subscribe and stick around for more
segments and more shows Monday through
Friday at 8 p.m.
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all in the next show
you